what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right
i'm here with santa oh and planet is
there remotely as well
don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five blockbuster has
three products you can buy and sell
crypto on crypto exchange you can earn
up to eight point six percent apy
in an interest bearing account or you
could deposit crypto take out a us
dollar loan against your crypto
collateral go get a block by account
block fight.com
santa said so santa said so go do it
let's
get it you do not need more toys in your
life
okay little fat guy over here let's roll
kids he's coming
all right treasury secretary steven
mnuchin told cnbc that
americans who qualify for direct
payments and the new coveted relief
legislation
could see that money hit their bank
accounts in a matter of
days he said people go out spend money
that helps small businesses and that
helps getting more people back to work
so it's very fast it's money that gets
recirculated in the economy
i have a feeling when people get that
check they're going to save it not spend
it what do you think
i think that a lot of people are going
to invest it they're going to go put it
into bitcoin they
will put into stock so you go stuff it
into the financial markets we're gonna
see asset prices explode
but politicians give me a break
you've been taking your salaries and you
gave the american people eighteen
hundred dollars
eighteen hundred dollars to survive a
global pandemic that's lasted nine
months
give me a break give him a break i can't
take you seriously with the santa but it
looks great
um people more money than you gave him
all right ready elon musk on sunday
asked about the possibility of
converting large transactions of tesla's
balance sheet and bitcoin
what do we think that means michael
saylor
who we met a few weeks ago ceo of
microstrategy
in a tweet to musk suggested the
billionaire uh
tesla founder and head make the move
what do you think
i think that every corporation at some
point in the future
could be a year from now could be 10
years from now is going to convert
some portion or a big portion of their
treasury into bitcoin
we will how long it takes
but i think that elon musk is likely to
do it with tesla
one he understands the macroeconomic
side two i actually think he's a big
bitcoin fan he tweeted the other day
people misread the tweet they thought he
was
making a negative comment about bitcoin
he was making a negative comment about
fiat currency and he's making a positive
comment about bitcoin and
three is uh he understands what happened
to microstrategy their stock price
the interest in the company etc elon
musk is one of the best marketers in the
world
do not be surprised if he goes and
converts some of uh their treasury even
if it is just 20 million dollars
into bitcoin it'll converge the bitcoin
crowd the tesla crowd
together it'll be the most rabid fan
base in the internet let's roll
speaking of elon spacex launched a
clandestine
u.s spy satellite into space for the
national
reconnaissance reconnaissance office
saturday marking its 26th rocket of the
year they've had a record year why are
you laughing at me
clandestine what did i say not that
clandestine what do you think about this
one clementine what
i think it's cool i think that i think
that uh spacex is
showing what could be done when private
companies work with government entities
and it's really cool he's faster it's
better it's
awesomer what do you think
i love it i think spacex is going to be
a once in a generation company
obviously so let's go santa likes it too
that's how santa's going
around the world nasa is moving ahead
with
work on a pair of mars sample return
missions
although some in the planetary science
community worry how the cost of that
effort will affect
other projects so basically it has
mars samples and
under the current plans uh sorry i don't
know what this is
basically there there's this thing
called the lander and the lander would
touch down near the landing site of the
mars 2020 mission
with the fetch rover collecting samples
cached by that mission
they're going to send the rover and then
the aliens on mars are going to take the
samples and load it
up and then they're going to send it
back oh i mean are there aliens on mars
i don't know
but i do think that uh obviously one of
the big pieces here is if they can send
a piece of machinery to mars have it
land
which is a wild uh engineering feat then
collect samples and then get it back
that will increase the odds that people
start to believe that interplanetary
travel is possible what does santa think
santa ain't worried man santa is just
saying by the way he's got real nice
combat boots on right
here he is ready to go to battle he
don't have no mask on he's going to be
coming down your chimney knees
he don't care what the politicians are
saying it was reported today that santa
has been vaccinated
kid yeah yeah yeah he's vaccinated sure
whatever
anthony listen to this i'm reading this
article and it's written by our friend
julia laroche
escape from new york analyst warns
exodus
exodus means the city won't be a
billionaire playground
anymore coveted lockdowns and advances
in remote technology
are prompting many to reconsider life in
the big apple and those with means are
relocating to lower cost havens like
florida near empty streets and office
buildings as well as
deteriorating quality of life issues
prompted jeffrey's
chief market strategist david zervos to
invoke
a cult classic move he basically
described
what should we move i mean
i'm moving all right if if you want me
to move
leave in the comments tell me what city
you want me to move to i'm out
i ain't dealing with these people no
more uh zervo said i'm bullish on the
get out of new york trade i don't think
this is a 911 storyline i think there's
something bigger and a lot of it comes
from work from home
get out of new york let's go me santa
and you we can go find somewhere better
and santa okay and this next we have one
ask lunch money question
guys if you have a question for us no
matter what it is
leave it in the comments with ask asklm
so i can find it easy
oh my god what are you doing over there
okay ready yes just one question
anthony i'm listening don't be
distracted
no go ahead i'm listening by ritwik
what are your thoughts on kathy wood in
arkhanvest they're one of the very few
investment firms that focus on
disruptive innovation and actually
endorse bitcoin and tesla early on
would you rate kathy in the same breath
as warren buffett
i think kathy wood is the best investor
on wall street right now
point blank period end of story don't
care what nobody's saying
she understands that investing in
innovation leads to
outsized returns she's been doing that
fantastic
uh way that's why people are giving her
more and more money
and so kathy wood pump boys motors
let's go
oh man and roanoke rapids that's where i
am right now
come say what's up to my dad awesome
see you guys tomorrow bang bang
hope you guys enjoyed this episode of
lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polena they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends